for working parents and carers managing
family life and professional career is
often a challenge especially for women
today women are still more likely to
take up caring responsibilities than men
this is one of the reasons why women are
still underrepresented on the labour
market although there represents 60% of
university graduates thanks to the
work/life balance directive the EU
introduces new minimum rights and
extends existing ones for working
parents and carers so that there's a
better sharing of care and
responsibilities within families the
work-life balance directive provides for
at least 10 working days of paternity
leave when a child is born paid sick pay
level at least four months of parental
leave two of those four months cannot be
transferred between parents and are
adequately paid at least five days of
leave per year for taking care of a
relative in need of significant care or
support the right to request flexible
working arrangements for all carers and
parents of children up to the age of at
least eight years these work-life
balance rules aim to offer both women
and men a real choice in finding the
right balance between their work and
family life this is fair and good for
families businesses member states and
the economy as a whole
[Music]